As much as he might like to be, the Merc with
a Mouth simply isn't one of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes.
"Pump the hate brakes, Thanos."
Deadpool star Ryan Reynolds sent a congratulatory
note to the Avengers: Infinity War cast over
the weekend as a way to applaud their accomplishments
and the film's record-breaking opening weekend.
But Ryan Reynolds being Ryan Reynolds, there
was a bit of snark in the post.
Reynolds posted a letter of dismissal from
the one and only Iron Man, which showed that
not only did the "genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist" reject Deadpool's plea to
join the team, but he was pretty mean about
it, too, writing: "No.
Absolutely not.
Go bother Professor X.
No."
"So dark.
Are you sure you're not from the DC Universe?"
While Tony might've come off angrier than
the Hulk in that note, Deadpool clearly isn't
holding a grudge because Reynolds said he
was glad that the Avengers never quit doing
what they do.
Chances are, Deadpool isn't the only one who'd
love to see himself link up with the super
hero squad, but he's been limited to living
in 20th Century Fox's extended X-Men movie
universe as a result of licensing issues that
sent Marvel's characters in separate directions.
However, with Disney's recent $52.4 billion
merger with Fox, which sees the House of Mouse
acquire most of the company's assets, that
might change a few years into the future.
"We're gonna form a super duper f---ing group."
For now, Marvel lovers can revel in the massive
madness of Avengers: Infinity War, out in
theaters now, before Deadpool 2 opens wide
on May 18.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!